wie geht es ihnen heute also die
mitglieder der jüdischen gemeinde in
halle stehen bis heute unter schock das
kann man schon so sagen
das sicherheitskonzept der synagoge
wurde verbessert aber die haben ja auch
gesagt wenn dort gottesdienst
stattfindet und jemand neues jemand
fremde steht in der tür dann schauen
alles sofort hin da ist was hängen
geblieben
auf der anderen seite und ich glaube
dass das an so einem tag total wichtig
zu sehen und zu sagen es gibt mehrere
überlebende die in diesem prozess kommen
wollen
die den attentäter anschauen wollen ins
gesicht schauen wollen in die augen
schauen wollen und ihm klar machen
wollen wir sind hier du hast uns nicht
gebrochen
wir sind da und haben am ende gewonnen
wenn man so will
was erwarten sie denn jetzt von diesem
prozess haben sie darüber schon
gesprochen ja also zwei große dinge
stehen im raum das eine ist gibt es
mitwisser mittäter finanziers am
gewissen aus dem manifest des
attentäters dass es da eine geldspende
feuer gab den ermittlern ist es nicht
wirklich gelungen zu rekonstruieren von
wem dieses geld kam das ist eine frage
na ja und das andere große thema man
muss ganz klar sagen die bundesrepublik
das land sachsen anhalt hat die menschen
dort im stich gelassen an dem tag
bestand an yom kippur keine polizei vor
der synagoge als sie angerufen haben
gesagt haben ihr schießt jemand kam
keine polizei und hier heute wird es
darum gehen dass das land sachsen anhalt
die behörden klar machen wie wir
schützen euch passt auf euch auf und wir
verfolgen den attentäter also wie du den
attentäter bei jetzt durch seine
recherchen ja fast kennen gelernt dass
wenn man das so sagen möchtest du auch
einen dass er jetzt diesen prozess
nutzen wird um eine schau daraus zu
machen ja das war eine sorge die wir
alle hatten und haben
man muss dazu wissen er ist ja
festgenommen worden dann gab es das
verhör was jörg auch gerade angesprochen
hat vier stunden und in den vier stunden
hat er gesagt dass er bereut unser
bereut nicht mehr menschen getötet zu
haben das ist seine weltsicht ein
krankhafter judenhass ein krankhafter
rassist wir haben es gehört seine
vorbilder haben die prozesse genutzt um
grüße zu machen hitlergruß szene
botschaften natürlich ist das eine sorge
die es heute und in diesem prozess auch
gibt auf jeden fall
danke max